♪♪
-I said samurais last week.
That is incorrect.
The plural of samurai
is samurai bricks.
[ Laughter ]
Men can also be gold diggers.
[ Coughs ] Prince Philip.
[ Laughter ]
I said a drug filled rampage.
The correct term
is a drug fueled rampage.
A drug fueled rampage happens
when you fill yourself
with drugs.
So...
I pronounce the name
of the Greek mathematician
Archimedes.
That was his nickname.
His full name
was Archibald Meads.
Speaking of that, I said,
I'm coming to terms
with the fact that
I've never said the word eureka,
and I probably never will.
Some of you saw that
as me setting it up
for a future "Corrections,"
and I'd call it back
and we'd all have a moment
because a callback is such
an effective comedy technique.
However, a few of you,
few eagle eyed viewers noted
that I actually have said eureka
in "Corrections" Episode 64.
Take a look.
Shoemaker and I share a wall,
if you're wondering.
That's why at 10:00 A.M.
you heard me scream eureka.
So did I make a mistake
when I said last week
that I have never said eureka?
I did not.
What I did was this.
A lot of you
have been complaining
about the YouTube playlist
and how it goes
in reverse order.
So it plays
the most recent one first
and then you're
watching it backwards.
So what I did is a comedy
technique called a call forward.
[ Laughter ]
It's when comedians are aware
that their audience
are watching their jokes
in reverse order.
What you will do is place
something in the future
that they will then
see in the past.
[ Laughter ]
I've been corrected multiple
times for saying Frankenstein
instead of Frankenstein's
monster.
This week
I did say it correctly,
but I said it correctly
as Donald Trump.
So then a bunch of you
jumped in and said Donald Trump
would never know
to make that distinction,
which has always been my point.
That has always been my point,
which just proves this
is a mathematical theorem,
I guess you would say,
called the Jackals Paradox,
in which there are
two paths forward
and neither one
makes you [bleep] happy.
[ Laughter ]
It is fair, I do think,
to make the observation
that Trump, excuse me,
would never say
Frankenstein's monster.
This is a man, remember,
who called Apple CEO Tim Cook
Tim Apple.
Don't think he's going to get
Frankenstein's monster right?
"I like I'd like to introduce
a man who's doing incredible
work in the field
of reanimation.
Victor Munster."
[ Laughter ]
I was told a female bear
is not called a woman.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, Turf.
I did misspeak.
A female bear is a sow.
And a male bear is a boar.
A male bear is called a boar
because they never stop
talking about fishing.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, the salmon were
really jumping today."
"I don't [bleep] care."
[ Laughter ]
I mentioned BDSM.
I was told that I had
over emphasized the D.
Then I said, you know anyone
who subjects themselves
to Correction every week, me, is
into a little D,
corrected again.
Doing this every week
is a combination of M,
I was told, for masochism
because I submit myself to this
humiliation and S for sadism
because I make
the crew stay for it.
[ Laughter ]
But you know what they say.
Can't have Seth Meyers
with a little S&M.
Oh, actually,
that's a proper name,
so they'd be capital S&M.
[ Groans ]
We had a herpes joke last week.
A jackal sent it in.
We thought it was really good.
That's why I told it
in last week's Correction.
A second jackal this week
wrote, "That herpes joke
was so funny
it should go viral."
So...
could be jackal
joke of the week.
Monday's Closer Look, we said
Trump isn't just the guy
who yells fire
in a crowded theater.
He's the guy
who lights the match,
pours the gasoline and screams
there's no point in leaving
because I've already changed --
I chained the exits.
A lot of you pointed out
when committing arson,
it's best to pour the gasoline
and then light the match.
We had light the match
and then pour the gasoline.
But again, is this another
jackal's paradox?
Would Trump know that?
We talked about Flaco the Owl.
And kind of story
we need right now,
and how people
originally were worried
that Flaco would not
be able to find food.
But then we pointed out,
owls eat rats
and he lives in New York City,
he's going to be fine.
Saying he would have trouble
finding food
would be like saying
a toddler would go hungry
in a chicken nugget factory.
You pointed out the nuggets
in a chicken nugget factory
would be frozen and a kid
wouldn't be able to eat them.
So thanks for pointing that out.
The hypothetical children
in that joke would go hungry.
[ Laughter ]
Someone sent in I hate to be
a downer, and let me tell you,
when a jackal
starts it like that...
[ Laughter ]
...my butthole clenches
right up.
[ Laughter ]
"I hate to be downer,
but they should continue
efforts to capture Flaco.
Flaco was a large predator,
and Central Park
is actually important habitat
for migratory
and resident birds.
They could become prey for Flaco
or be negatively impacted
by Flaco's presence.
When Flaco kills someone's
unleashed small dog..."
Pt him on a leash.
"When Flaco kills
someone's unleashed small dog,
what will people think?
It's not Flaco's fault,
but Flaco shouldn't live
forever in the wild in New York.
He doesn't belong there."
In that case, Kenny,
I gave you the green light.
[ Laughter ]
Kenny's been walking around --
Kenny Cole's been walking
around, "If it was me,
that owl would
have been caught yesterday."
[ Laughter ]
Another jackal submission
for Joke of the Week.
I said owls are smart
because they're often drawn
with graduation caps.
Jacob wrote in and said, Pigeons
are actually the smartest birds.
"Pigeons are actually
the smartest birds
because some coo quietly
but some will coo loudly."
I didn't write it, Baz.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about how we wanted
to crowd source
with our jackal
our Emmy submission.
And by the way, a lot of you
said I don't have Twitter.
Just write it in the comments
of the, you know,
the YouTube comments where you
do all your other business.
66, Episode 66
seems to be a frontrunner.
It was our Christmas episode.
69, also very popular.
Shoemaker told me
69 was his favorite,
and then he winked so hard
it cracked my contact lens.
[ Laughter ]
The spectacular. Some --
there were some confused.
The spectacular is not
and has never been
an episode of Corrections.
If it's anything, it is,
and this is off
the top of my head.
Outstanding Variety Special
(Prerecorded).
I guess we mentioned bacteria.
Oh, yeah, it was
about water bottles.
How many -- how much
bacteria there is on
people's water bottles.
Somebody wrote, "Correction,
bacteria gets a bad rap.
There's good bacteria
and bad bacteria
insofar as impact
on human health.
You know, yogurt, that thing
that people think is so healthy?
What's healthy about it
is the bacteria,
neutral bacteria exist, too."
So sounds like somebody's
restaurant got a bad
health code rating.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, on "Frasier," I said the dog
who played Eddie
was named Moose,
and after he died,
he was replaced by his son Enzo.
And then I implied that the
circumstances around his death
were suspicious, and Enzo,
while ultimately cleared,
was always suspected
of shenanigans.
I was wrong.
The show ended in 2004.
Moose died in 2006,
so Moose was still alive
when Enzo replaced him.
Moose could not continue
with the show
because Enzo had put him
in a retirement home
against his will.
[ Laughter ]
Also someone wrote,
their exact words,
"Fun fact,
Enzo died in 2010."
[ Laughter ]
We showed a clip
in A Closer Look,
because the Closer Look,
obviously,
is about the day's events.
We try to write it
about everything that happened
over the course
of the last 24 hours.
I think what makes it vital
and important is the fact
that it is so connected
to the day's news.
We showed a clip in the body
of A Closer Look
of Major League Baseball's
spring training in 2001,
in which Randy Johnson
threw a pitch
that hit a bird
which then exploded.
We had to.
It's in the news.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, you know, and there was
no way there was --
It was just an accident.
I'm not going to show
the clip again,
but Randy Johnson threw 100
mile per hour fastball
right as a -- as a dove,
it turned out,
was flying through.
The type of bird
I was told was a mourning dove,
not M-O-R-N,
M-O-U-R-N.
That was the name,
A mourning dove.
So already mourning,
flies through a baseball field,
gets exploded with a baseball.
It's like a hearse
going off the side of a cliff.
[ Laughter ]
Also, you know, we showed it.
And much like even
talking about it now,
it kind of chills the room,
the story about
a dove getting
exploded with a baseball.
And I said to
the audience that night,
because it did the same then
and they had to watch the clip,
I said,
"If it makes it easier,
that bird would have died
of old age by now."
I was told not necessarily.
[ Laughter ]
Some doves live to be
30 years old.
So how that happened --
not happened,
probably be happily
in retirement right now.
Also, no one dies of old age.
I said dies of old age.
"No one dies of old age.
I was told as you get older,
you just get more
susceptible to illness.
Or in the case of Moose
the Dog, foul play.
[ Laughter ]
Randy Johnson,
Hall of Fame pitcher,
true story,
is a professional
photographer now.
I am not making this up.
This very much will look like
a thing I'm making up.
Someone pointed this out to me,
I went to the website.
Randy Johnson is
a professional photographer
and this is the logo
of Randy Johnson photography.
[ Laughter ]
So we covered Moose, Enzo
and the dove.
Randy Johnson exploded.
This has been Animal Deaths.
-Animal Deaths.
[ Laughter ]
-I mentioned last week
that I threw away
all my Mac Tonight
merchandise.
Well, it reappeared on my desk
with a note
from building maintenance,
saying it was scaring
the other garbage.
[ Laughter ]
So we're back. By the way,
some people like this stuff.
When I'm walking down,
I could tell they're jealous
because,
you know, I usually have it
on a big tray or in a box.
And I'll walk down the hall
carrying my Mac Tonight
merchandise.
I often hear people say...
-Where does he get those
wonderful toys?
-See, that works.
[ Laughter ]
See how much better it is if the
Nicholson quote fits the setup?
We just take this
as a teachable moment.
You know, if we're on the same
page, the sky is the limit.
What if...
What if we could make this show
better every week?
-What if this
is as good as it gets?
-Oh, [bleep] you.
[ Laughter ]
See me next week.
Two weeks.